we've seen these reports in multiple
media outlets that russia has asked
china to supply it with weapons the fact
we're seeing them in multiple media
outlets suggest this is the us trying to
get ahead of it especially as its top
diplomat meets china's top diplomat to
discuss international relations and we
haven't heard of course what china has
said in response to this inquiry but it
does raise the specter of chinese
weapons making their way into ukraine
which would ultimately be an escalation
of this conflict now there are reasons
to think this won't happen despite
china's deep partnership with russia
they talk of a partnership which knows
no limit this would carry a lot of risk
first of all it would definitely
antagonize the eu and china has been
trying to repair that relationship with
eu leaders even if it doesn't care
really about its relationship with us in
the same way it does see ground that can
be made secondly all through this crisis
china has been saying that people
sending weapons to ukraine is talking
about the west in this instance they are
merely pouring fuel on the fire so to do
the same thing would lead to accusations
of hypocrisy and it would also torpedo
china's role as a mediator it said that
this should be solved by diplomacy not
conflict and if it's supplying weapons
to russia that becomes a lot harder to
sustain now that doesn't mean it can't
still happen there is that deep
partnership but it's important to judge
it by deeds and not words the words
we'll see over the next hours and the
next days but it is a possibility a
nightmarish scenario that you would have
ukraine and russia in conflict with the
west supplying weapons to ukraine china
supplying weapons to nato that really
would be a new cold war